And now the old scout master
Trail
mix. It has trail in the name. It tastes like trail. I
had this. I was sure I'd been into a twig. I'll
tell you what they do. They put M&M's in there to fool you. So
you're about to spit it out. You go: oh twig, Oh
no, M&M, No
twig. Now
that's a twig M&M.
I Make
my own trail mix. now It's a one-pound bag of M&M. Comedian
John Panette. Yeah,
on trail mix, I agree, John. My
trail mix is a one-pound bag of M&M. sounds good to me. Hey,
this is podcast. You.
Welcome
back to the Scout master podcast. This is Clark Green. Hey, looking in the mail bag, Let's
see over on iTunes. another five-star on iTunes titled
give me strength and, And
it is left for us here by long-time scouter. great podcast, Clark. You
offer great lessons and experiences that make my job a lot easier. You've
given me the confidence to lead a contingent to the 2013
National Jamboree. not sure what I've signed up for, but I'm really looking forward to the experience. any further guidance on How
to plan for this event? we're planning several unit meetings with our newly assembled troop and we appreciate your thoughts on logistics.
I Not
going to be at the National Jamboree. Actually, I was offered a scout master position, but
Scheduling
and money- That's what's not working for me, because we're on our second trip to Switzerland
in 2014.
2013,
I'm committed to a canoe trip up to Canada and so jamboree time just isn't going to cut it and It's
just so expensive- Wow, It's
like almost as much as going to Switzerland for us, So
we had to kind of make a decision about that. but you are going and Thoughts
on logistics and things. Well, you know, the way that this works is you get a contingent
troop and Rather
than spending any time messing around with logistics and thinking about that, I
would concentrate very heavily on the effectiveness of your patrols and patrol leaders. I remember
that when I went, way
back in the day, we Appointed
patrol leaders and that was a big mistake. Don't do that. Get
the boys together several times and Have
some activities where they can just be together as a big bunch and let them form their own patrols and let them elect
their own patrol leaders, maybe two or three meetings in, because
most of the things that they're going to end up doing at the jamboree are going to be patrol based, and I
mean, if the jamboree is run, Anything
similar to what it was when I went- Oh
gosh, it's, it's been five or six jamborees ago- the, the makeup of the patrol and the
effectiveness of the patrol leader- seemed to be like the principal
pivot point that the jamboree experience went on. for an individual scout- if he had, if it was in a decent patrol on- the Patrol
leader was a good patrol leader. He got around, He saw a lot of stuff and they had a pretty good time. If
the patrol was meh and the patrol leader was meh, they had kind of a meh time. So That's
my, that's my best Advice
to you. you know gear and everything. they're gonna have all your gear there. The
other thing that I've read about the jamboree that I think is really encouraging is they're they're favoring younger scout leaders, So
people who are in their 20s rather than people who are in their 40s and 50s like you and I. So
I think that is very, very positive And
you will have one in your troop and I would do my best to put them forward at every opportunity. So
my best jamboree advice right there. I got to one early on and I I'm
gonna miss this one. Maybe we'll get to one in the future, Who knows, But
I think it'll be an exciting time at the summit- the first national jamboree there at the summit- and Let
us know how it goes. Would you further into the mailbag? bob holster says: excellent advice For
both new and experienced scout masters. Thanks, Well. thanks, bob. Thanks
for the kind words and thanks for being in touch. Greg Come says: thank you so much for your podcast. How
do I do download the older podcast from the archives? All right, so you get to the archives page. first of all, Go
to scoutmastercgcom. scoutmastercgcom.
Go
to the archives page. You
will see a big long table of uh podcasts there and there's a little play button for each podcast. Right
click with your mouse And
then, according to the browser you're using, you're going to see the option to save file as or download or something
Like
that. click on that option when it comes up in the menu after you, right click on the play button And
then you'll be able to download it to your hard drive. How about that? And thanks for being in touch, Greg. I'm
I'm glad you're finding the podcast useful. We
scout or got in touch any uh referring to podcast 113 Where
we had the scout master panel discussion. part of what we talked about was blue cards. He
says. you know that was a great podcast. Unfortunately
my son and I are leaving a troop because of many reasons, But
a big one is the leader's misinterpretation of the use of blue cards. Our
scout master would not approve a blue card for my son who was going to a registered counselor, Because
it caused a scheduling conflict. Well, that is a sad story. that scout master has got Things
a little back to front. You're
not in control of a boy schedule. If he wants to challenge americ badge, let him go ahead. It's his choice. Sometimes
they make it, sometimes they don't, but it's none of your business. Sign
the blue card, Would you please? Thank you very much. BA
scouter says: got back from andrew skirka's gear and skills presentation in iowa city a few minutes ago. We
had to travel two hours but it was well worth it. We
had some great dad and son time to and from the presentation and learned a lot of good info from andrew. Uh,
an added benefit is the renewed high level of enthusiasm My
son has towards his scouting goals. a big thanks to andrew for getting out and doing what he's doing And
thank you, by the way, for persevering with andrew to get the interview and that interview, I think, is one 11
podcast, number 11, And
I hear that there were some challenges. Yeah, there were a couple of little challenges, it
was just scheduling stuff. andrew skirka is the author of New
gear guide and we had him on the podcast a couple times ago And,
uh, we interviewed him and andrew is just like this incredible Backpacking
massive hiker. I mean he has, if I have the numbers right, he has hiked Equal
to two and a half times around the earth's equator, like 30 000 miles in the past decade, Which
is just floors me. He
wrote a great book and he is on a speaking tour right now And
that's what caused the the difficulties getting him for the interview. Uh,
you know, he was on his own. He's driving or flying between cities and, uh, you know, staying in hotels And
anybody who's been on business travel know what that's like. So
his schedule was a little unpredictable But
he finally found some time to sit down and talk to us and I'm really glad he did. I'm
glad, uh, ba Scatter, that you got out there To
uh his talk in Iowa City. take a look on andrew's website to see What
the remainder of his speaking schedule is. And,
of course, he leads trips and events and everything. and if you check with us at scoutmastercgcom, You
can also read my review of his book. It's
so nice when people get in touch and they let me know how things are going. I
get a number of email questions and comments every week And
I want you to become a part of the conversation Now.
I periodically try to remind everybody about this, but, uh, if you think about what I am doing right now, I'm
sitting in my office at home, I'm talking into a microphone, I'm
watching as my words are recorded and then I'm going to edit them And
I'm going to put them up on the web and people are going to download them and listen to them And
that's all great and you know, a fair number of people find this useful. still amazes me, but they do. And
here's the only thing that I ask of you: Get
in touch, Let me know what you're thinking, Let me know if the podcast is useful to you, Let
me know if I get something wrong- Certainly, and people do- Let
me know where you are and what you're doing in scouting. This
needs to be a conversation. I
need to hear back from you, and you can do that very simply by going to scoutmastercgcom and filling out the contact form. You
can also email me at scoutmastercg, at verizonnet, scoutmastercg
at verizonnet And
there's a couple other ways you can stay in touch. There's social media stuff. You
can even give us a phone call, but you'll hear about that towards the end of the podcast. So,
on this podcast and scoutmaster ship, in seven minutes or less we're going to talk about contribution syndrome. Maybe that's a familiar, uh, a
familiar subject. If
it isn't, it soon will be. and
then we're going to reach back into, uh, the history of radio And,
uh, we can play a little, uh, part of a radio show for you That
I found about an old, uh, it's a kind of a superhero scoutmaster. Oh,
that's right. I hear squeals of glee out there from a few of you and some of you really could care less, but That's
right. We're going to hear from brick mason And
then we're going to go back into the archives to podcast number 65 for a scoutmasters minute And,
uh, that's the whole podcast today, That's right. So let's get started. Shall we scoutmaster Ship
in seven minutes or
less. David
axon is the author of the management myth busters And
he asserts That
successful leaders ask great questions. great questions, not lots of questions necessarily. Now,
i'm a big fan of scoutmasters asking questions and not doing a whole lot of declarative, You
know, telling, Telling
scouts what to do, but helping them to discover What
to do through asking questions. My
personal problem is that I talk way too much. Hey,
you're listening to me on a podcast. Come on, I like to talk, I
like to talk to people. I I really enjoy talking to scouts. I don't think they enjoy it quite so much as I do. You
know, sometimes I just get on a terror and I natter away and I watch all the interest in life and engagement In
my scouts faces turn into this kind of bleak despair, Like
when is he going to shut up? Have
you had that experience? Oh
well, So
join the club. I
read, uh, david axon's description. I've
diagnosed myself And
I have what's called contribution syndrome. That's right. Here's
his description of a contribution syndrome. Is
this? no matter what the situation, It's
the compulsion to contribute, to show how smart you are at every possible opportunity. Our
whole merit system is based on On
getting the answer right. as we move into the business world. contribution syndrome Infects
are every poor. We
must be seen to be contributing in every meeting or in every project. For
some, this manifests itself in a complete inability to quietly sit and listen. It
seems part of their dna to feel they are That
if they are not talking then they are not working. armed with this knowledge, You
know I readily recognize the compulsion That
I have to contribute all the time I have to get my two
cents in. Axon
goes on to explain it this way. He says the best leaders stop talking,
That
I stopped talking there. I was practicing. they sit quietly, Taking
the contributions of everyone else and limiting their own contribution to asking a few pertinent
questions That
lead the discussion in a constructive manner. Great
questions Are
not complex questions. In fact, the best seem blindingly obvious. Unfortunately,
a relative small proportion of people in leadership positions have the courage, Confidence
or even the basic communication sense To
ask the right questions. The
most potent question anyone can ever ask is the simple three letter inquiry Why
The
key is to keep asking dumb but great questions. This
demonstrates a level of humility that is essential for effective leadership. I
want to say that again because I really like the way that that is phrased. the key is to keep asking dumb
But
great questions. This
demonstrates a level of humility That
is essential for effective leadership. complexity
has become synonymous with sophistication. How
do we get better at asking great questions? We
practice, We
practice. So
what does this actually boil down to for you as a scout leader? Well,
sometimes it's just asking why. Sometimes
it's just asking why, and sometimes that's a rhetorical question. I ask myself: Why
are we doing this this way? Is
it because it's A
particularly effective way to make things happen, or is it just the way that we've become used to? Why
are we Instructing
this way? Is it a good way to instruct, or is it just the Easiest
one that we can come up with? is just, you know, the one that we can come up with? This
can be a little aggravating. I aggravate myself sometimes. If
you're aggravated with me, imagine what it's like now anyway. but uh, Sometimes
just asking that simple three-letter inquiry, as axon puts it, why We'll
begin to open the world into another way of looking at things That
will help you create a better experience for your scouts- And
a better experience for your scouts is always the one that they make for themselves. Why
are we doing things this way? Why do we make, uh, the scouts do this particular thing, or Why
do we have a prohibition against that particular thing. All
these things should stand up to good logic, and I think they're questions we should ask frequently. It's
also a wonderful way To
help guide boys to think for themselves: Why
are you doing what you're doing right now? That's
a Can
be kind of an unsettling question for for a scout, And
if it's asked in a spirit of actual inquiry and humility, You
get some very interesting answers. So
I want to encourage you to Think
about two things. One
is contribution syndrome- And
you know, hey, if you have it, welcome to the club, And
you may just be aware of that and you may want to stop talking quite so much. I
know that I've been working on it for a long time. Oh, it gets better after a while. but- And
the other one is: is that great questions are not complex questions? And
complexity, Accident
says, has become synonymous with sophistication. So
we think that if something is terribly complex and and convoluted and complicated, Well,
that means that it's very sophisticated and and smart. not necessarily so. Hey,
I hope that's useful for you. Let
me know what your thoughts are. you can get in touch and I'm going to tell you how to do that in just a moment. So
This
is Cliff Jacobson and you're listening to the scout master podcast with Clark green. I'm
marked by a lack of truth. The
world turns to. I
find that the purchase of new camping equipment is necessary both to safety, Comfort
and, being an exemplary scout master, I
am also able to demonstrate to my scouts a number of options available to them In
the way of camping accoutrements done over there. Have you got your tents set up? Yeah, they're all set up. Mr
Ram wants to talk to everybody again. Yeah, come on over here, fellas. Do
we have scouts gather around over here? gather around? I think mr Ram wants to. I don't. yeah, Come
on. Hi, mr Ram, Have
I your- uh, Undivided
attention? I
think so. It
is my pleasure to announce that I have obtained a new 10 security engineered structured fabric shelter. Yeah
right, Mr
Ram, What
is it? 10 security engineered structured fabric shelter? Yeah, that's what she said the first time: a canvas, A
domicile, perhaps, I don't know what, a tent? Oh
well, why didn't you say that in the oh? I mean, that would have been easier if you just told us you bought a new tent, you know, And
I would now like to demonstrate the features of this shelter to you, For
it is made out of the most a lot of current space age materials. This
particular tent is constructed with an elaborate system of poles that support the fabric shell. Wow, The
first pole must be a big tent. and let me see, get the poles. Oh, be careful. The
first set of poles Is
17 feet. you don't want to pinch your finger by a assembling pole number one in Taking
that, And
into pole number 43 we can. They
are put like, so Inserted
into the ground, And
then a parabola is developed by bending the pole from its anchoring point to watch out a
another point. Oh,
That's
a long way. he went all the way up in the tree. Are you okay up there in the tree, mr M? Um,
I wonder if one of you would be good enough to
loan me Your
cellular telecommunications. to that, mr M, I remember you told us we weren't allowed to bring them. Yeah, Yeah, that's right. Yeah,
Did
bring my own, but it seems to have been dislodged. Oh, yeah, from my pocket. Yeah,
during my flight through the air. Yeah, this tree. Would
one of you be good enough to retrieve it? Well,
we're not supposed to go in the lake, because I think I saw it go in the lake. I see At
that. well, yeah, Could
we perhaps? yeah, One
of you would be good enough to consult the ranger as to the presence Of
a ladder here in camp. Yeah, john went to do that already. Thank
you, scouts. The demonstration has concluded. Thank you, mr M. Mr M, Join
us again for another exciting episode in the career of Jones.
Well,
this past weekend we had an Eagle Court of Honor with our troop, Two
of our guys having reached the rank of Eagle, and we had a presentation for them. and, uh, you know what I
got to say a few words, surprising, isn't it? Yeah,
I know, I
tried to keep it brief. This
is what I had to share with everybody who attended our Eagle Court of Honor. Boys
joint scouting as they begin to leave childhood and enter the years of transition into adulthood. During
these years they're both predictable and Kind
of unpredictable. We
think times have changed and that things are so radically different. But
boys are still much like they were a century ago when scouting started. They
have the same basic interests, talents and needs. They
act on the same basic instincts and motivations. as a crowd They're pretty predictable. But
as individuals, Well,
you never can tell. at this point in their lives They wake up in a new world every morning. Who
knows what they'll be thinking and doing today. Yesterday
they may have been really passionate about skateboarding or something like that, and tomorrow they'll have their heart set on a career in medicine. I
mean, who can tell? Scouting
accepts all this uncertainty and presents boys with a set of surmountable obstacles That
help them ask the right questions and guide them towards the right answers. Scouting
provides a safe environment to exercise real responsibility, where failure has real consequences And
where success is rewarded, and it's rewarded by the satisfaction of Scouts
doing something for themselves And
serving the interests of others. Each
one of them is going to make their own way, But
only four percent of boys who become scouts make it to an eagle court of honor. Over
the years, our scouts have gone from here to do some pretty remarkable things. They've
become college professors and army captains and engineers, and teachers and television personalities, lawyers, executives, doctors, salesmen and tradesmen. As
diverse as all those pursuits are, they share some common characteristics: They've
also become decent, contributing citizens with a sense of service and decent human beings with a sense of compassion. Now
that's our measure of success and that's our aim. Our
eagle scouts stand to strive their futures. It'll
be some time before we know what they'll become, But
they approach the future having succeeded, having proven to themselves They have what it takes. This
badge, this medal they received today are symbols of this achievement, And
as symbols, they're a reminder that these young men can do whatever they set out to accomplish. So
Well,
thanks once again for listening to this edition of the scout master podcast. now Here's how to keep in touch. First
of all, you can read the scout master blog at scoutmastercgcom And
there you can subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email. You
can also subscribe to the scout master podcast on itens, and when you do, we sure feel great when somebody leaves us a comment or
review or a rating. You
can also access the podcast on your mobile device through stitcher smart radio, And
you get details about that at stitchercom. You.
You
can also leave a voicemail comment or question at 484-734-0002. You
want to be on the podcast? call and leave a voicemail comment or question and you just might hear it on the next podcast. You.
You
can also experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama of social media outlets. Follow
us at scoutmaster blog on facebook, tweet scoutmastercg on twitter and, for admittance to the exclusive scoutmastercg circle. Search
for scoutmastercg on google plus. if you don't bother with any of that stuff, If
you don't face, you don't tweet and you don't plus, just email me. that's right, Email
me, clark green, your comments, questions and wild ideas at
scoutmastercg, at
verizonnet. And
The
scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America, Nor
are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America. No,
no, no. it's just me talking into a microphone trying to lend a hand to scout leaders And
maybe have a little bit of fun along the way. Before
we leave you, let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell. Sir Robert, Good
luck to you and good campus Why?
thank you, sir, until next time You.